welcome back everyone before we conclude
this module i just want to share a few
final thoughts about blockchains
the first thing that's really important
to remember is that a blockchain is not
always the right application for storing
data yeah so a blockchain is a really
good tool whenever you need to whatever
you need to have the ability to verify
publicly all the transactions that are
being issued in your system
and when centralization is not an option
yeah in particular
if you're in a situation where you don't
want to trust a single party or a small
number of parties for persistence and
liveness
then uh that's that's the case where you
should be using a blockchain if one of
these is not really true
you don't need a blockchain really what
you need is a database or maybe in some
cases what's called a distributed
database
it's really important to remember that a
blockchain is the right solution only
for certain types of data for most data
a database or distributed database are
perfectly fine
so that's the first thing to remember
don't always jump to
proposing blockchain as a solution
the second
thought i want to make sure is clear
is that data we talk about data on the
blockchain but really data is not
typically on the blockchain most of the
time the blockchain is just used to
authenticate data so what do i mean by
that
really if you have a large document you
don't really want to put that large
document on the blockchain because the
blockchain gets replicated all over the
world and it would just be causing a lot
of storage headaches for a lot of people
all over the world instead what we
typically do is we compute a hash of the
large document maybe the large document
is like a couple of megabytes big we
just compute this short hash remember
these are 32 byte
hashes and we only put the hash on the
blockchain the point is that now
once the document is presented to
someone anyone can verify its
authenticity by just looking that the
correct hash is
stored on the blockchain so the
blockchain itself sort of stores hashes
it typically does not store actual
document values
that's the second point to remember
the third point i want you to remember
is that
there are issues with blockchain scaling
so in fact on the main blockchains
bitcoin ethereum and so on uh
the transaction rate is not where we
would want it to be and a good example
of this is when the cryptokitties
applications launched we talked about
cryptokeys earlier when it launched it
was so popular that in fact the
transaction rated rate that was
generated just by the cryptokitties
contract
already that exceeded the throughput
that ethereum can can support so if you
want to read about what happened there
there's a good there's a good overview
in this story that i that i mentioned
here that i cite here you can look this
up
but effectively uh you know the
transaction rate was so high just from
this one dap that no one could issue
transactions uh for a while on the
blockchain yeah so
so this shows that scaling really is
kind of an important issue for these for
these blockchains and so let's just look
at some numbers
if you look at the visa network visa can
handle a roughly you know 1600
transactions per second the paypal
network that's just us based can handle
around 130 193 transactions per second
in comparison you know the large the
large blockchains are much much much
slower
and as a result um you know this is why
we see this contention in transaction
rates when kind of a very popular
application launches
now i have to say there are lots and
lots of there's a lot of work on scaling
blockchains and in fact new blockchain
designs aim to support much much much
higher rates
um but it turns out that even the
traditional blockchains like bitcoin and
the classic ethereum can also be made to
scale so let me say a few words about
that
um so there are many proposed solutions
for just scaling bitcoin and ethereum
one example is something called a
lightning lightning network for bitcoin
and plasma for ethereum
this is really quite a beautiful idea in
that what happens is most transactions
are executed off the main chain yeah so
the main bitcoin chain or the main
ethereum chain kind of progress at their
slow rates
but then most of the transactions don't
even touch those main chains so it
doesn't really matter if those
transactions if those chains are slow
given that most transactions happen
off-chain yeah so the idea here is
basically when you initialize an uh kind
of the virtual chain
or when you exit from this virtual chain
or when there's problem where this where
there's disagreement between parties
this is when you need to hit the main
chain but in most cases where the system
kind of works without many problems or
the system is already being initialized
and people just issue transactions most
of the transactions just happen period
up here and they never really touch the
main chain so if you want to read a bit
more about how this works you can look
up the lightning network it's actually
quite easy to understand how lightning
works
plasma is also quite a beautiful design
so that's one approach for scaling yeah
the way we scale is simply we don't
touch the main we touch the main chain
as little as possible
so that's one idea and the second idea
is sharding which is basically to split
up the blockchain into multiple
partitions each partition is called a
shard and so there are lots of designs
for sharding the difficulty that happens
with sharding is when you need to move
uh value from one shard to another
that's where kind of complications
happen because now you need to talk
between different partitions of the
blockchain and you know there are some
interesting complications that come up
in making that work yeah so but anyhow
these are proposals that are
specifically designed for scaling up
bitcoin and ethereum as i said there are
other more recent blockchains that are
being proposed that actually scale
inherently can handle hundreds of
thousands of transactions a second so in
the long run the scaling issue
is likely not going to be a problem
okay the last thing i want to say
is that uh this topic is vast i hope i
kind of gave you a sense of the
different areas of this topic basically
from mining from consensus protocols for
managing crypto assets and by the end
user
there are many many many topics in this
area and we kind of only covered a
little bit of each topic kind of only
the tip of the iceberg
it's a fascinating area i really love it
there's a lot of excitement and a lot of
deep scientific questions happening here
if you want to learn more
we offer a complete course on
blockchains it's called cs251
anyone can sign up i
read i wrote the instructions here
if you are interested in reading more
about how these blockchains work there's
a nice there's a very nice book on
bitcoins and cryptocurrencies available
on amazon it's written by um
uh you know well-respected academics in
the space
and so that's another uh source for
information and then i've i've also
given you a bunch of sources throughout
the lecture that you can look up more
material on your own and everything i've
i've listed is self-contained and
something that you can actually spend a
few minutes and read and kind of get a
better sense
on your own so i hope you do look into
some of the material in a bit more
detail as i said it's really uh
interesting and kind of a fun fun area
so i hope to see you get into it and
good luck with the further studies and i
will see you at the future modules for
this course
so we'll stop here and thank you very
much